that though do you think as a woman
though you can be in love with more than
one man
no
i think there's love on different levels
okay yeah but i feel like you can maybe
you can be in love with different people
for different things
yeah like i feel like you don't believe
all right
you can you can be in love with just one
person you can love multiple people
right but you can only be in love with
one person
you know there's a difference with like
loving
people and like being actually in love
with someone and being well like wanting
to sacrifice everything you have like
for them like you you don't want to do
that for multiple people there i feel
like there's just one person that you'd
want to do that for
you so you can you can be in love with
more than one man i disagree only
because i can see it from like a
friendship level was all like i have
this friend here like she's literally
like my sister i'll do anything for her
and i have like different friends
but i feel like that kind of that kind
of problem we're talking about in love
with my friends
but what defines love like love is love
love is love but i mean like is it
because i'm sexually intimate with that
person yeah
is that not is that not like a different
sector of that are you sexually intimate
with her no
so do are you in love with her but love
is love no
no there's different types
so you think that the love you have for
your parents is the same type of love
that you have for the guy you're
sleeping with yeah like come on why are
we
you can only be in love with one person
in one time
that's what i'm saying i'm saying as a i
know
and i'm a man myself
well i can be in love
with more than one woman in love in love
[Music]
like and that's the thing about love
though because it's
it's a personal thing isn't it you know
what i mean like so
i'm not because it wasn't no but i'm
saying love is a personal thing but i
know i can be in love with more than one
woman but even if you were i've actually
been there wouldn't you at one point you
value i feel like it's just natural for
us to value one more than the other
as a woman no even as
a human you didn't have a favorite as a
human being
for different reasons because if that
makes sense yeah but you didn't have one
like
no no for different like if i if i have
like if i'm in love with like two women
i'm not by the way this just get out
there right
like so if
you love them
you're in love with them for different
reasons and they
they
tick different boxes
than the other one but you love
different things about them that you may
not get in the other person you're going
with my point about friendships as well
though because we all have different
friends with different that's not sex
like sexual love is different from your
parents sometimes
like love is love can i just wait let me
finish my quote love is love and i feel
like each person that's what i
understand i so understand polyamorous
relationships right like i feel like
different people do different things for
you so why you love for them it's what
they can do for you right and what they
bring out of you
right yeah that's why i completely
understand it so what you really did say
is kind of contradicting it no i mean
but i think you're telling me like no
it's not different it's not no but love
conventions bring different things for
you as to why you have different love
for different people yeah but the thing
is with your partner
or partners you're going to have a
sexual side of the relationship of
course so
that's not the same kind of love as you
have for your sibling or your mother or
your father or your friend yeah or your
friend is like what are what are you
arguing like i just feel like you're
arguing nothing like you're
but
like
he's saying he has a sexual love for two
different girls
yeah yeah sexual love yeah because sex
is involved within
differentiates that
what is it well i don't have sex with my
siblings or my mom or my dad right like
you've been loving like two different
girls so he wasn't like two different
girls yes what difference is that
because you're getting sex from both
those girls yes what differentiates that
makes you think but what makes us go
more or is it like you don't even
there's no there's no more or less okay
i was in love with both of those women
at that time
was that i mean like i was in love with
both of those women yeah yeah was that
like a like an open relationship or
something no no it really wasn't
actually it was a situationship type
situation but it was in my like 20s and
stuff
yeah it was like an entanglement
no but it was like when i was in my 20s
i actually felt like i was in love with
two different women that's what i'm
saying polyamorous relationships like
yeah i feel like
literally different people do different
things for you and brings out a
different side to you and what like who
you are as a person so i do understand
like
why people do end up polyamorous
relationships so you think women can do
the same thing be in love with two men
and
three men four men at the same time
completely like yeah i wouldn't even put
sexual assault i wouldn't quantify that
personally because i can't speak from
experience
um but i feel like it is possible
looking at
experience i've heard from other people
people can't like even women i'll say
women's experience that i've heard from
um you can be in love with two people
i feel like it's like men
it's about what they bring for you and
what they bring out of you
it just depends on the person and this
goes back to what i was saying earlier
on about
uh
human beings being in a more polyamorous
or polygamous relationship prior to
this system that we currently have and i
i really do think i just part i mean it
just thinks that we're
reverting back to
that time
and the thing is this kind of schism
that we're having
this oh men are trash women are trash i
think this is the i think that's the the
i think that's well it's because
no it's because we're all sleeping with
the same guys so women think men are
trash because we're all sleeping with
the same ones okay and then men think
women are trash because these all these
guys can't get laid and the girls they
do get laid from like don't give a [ __ ]
about them because they they don't
actually want them they just like that
i think so i think it's like the bottom
i know i think it's like the bottom like
i the bottom like 80 percent of guys or
whatever 50 percent of guys they're the
angry ones at women
typically because the guy the girls
talking about like the incels yeah yeah
right yeah
or okay i have two things um
one i think that
women can
be in love with two people but i think
is more so
what happens to women is this
relationship they have over here
there's a distance they're still in love
with that person but there's a distance
and then they go
to another person that they're not in a
relationship with and they end up
falling in love with them and there was
just
an emotional disconnect with the first
person i think that happens more so
than them being in love with
two people i i agree because i feel like
girls like
like i feel like i've only been in love
twice right but i feel like both of
those guys like i'll always you are
they're the same type of love
you love them the same
uh what do you mean
um
no i mean the relationships were
different right like they're they're
completely different um
but i feel like i still like
there's a party that always like cares
about someone if you've spent enough
time with them for long enough
yeah there's like
yeah but that's that's what i said
earlier i feel like marriages would be
better with like lots of those
right you know
so
so then you can see that
you can love it
right but i would have two different
people differently
yeah but actually yeah but i wouldn't
say like i'm still in love with either
does that make sense
i get that but i'm saying you understand
that you can be in love with two
different oh yeah because they were like
yeah they were they the two guys were
very different yeah yeah yeah and they
they probably brought out different
sides of you in that relationship no i'm
pretty weird regardless
i'm crazy no matter who i'm with you
completely
bring out different sides of you nothing
like that's all aspects of relationships
that can be parents
like mother or father
like whichever um friends and like your
partner like not genderflying them like
it's literally each other like it
depends on what they bring out of you
like what you connect with i think
that's like an emotional there's just
different aspects like sexual emotional
mentally like spiritually
how many times have you been in love
would you say
zero
you've never been in love wow like i
really felt like
in love like on that level
like that i think i've heard people
describe but i think it's all um altered
to each individual's experience but
you've never experienced it i don't feel
like i've experienced in love
i knew
oh my god
um anyways let's just talk about the
first two okay okay so yeah so there's a
third
i wouldn't
absolutely i wonder because you know i'm
still getting to know this man so i
don't know yet okay i like the man i
like that yes you should be a man yes
well yes who wants a boy
um the first one was the one that
cheated on me
hurt my heart the second one
so like we weren't we were never
official anything right but i think we
both knew that you were in love that we
both were and then were the same was the
same type of love
yeah i would say it was a little more
intense what was more intense the one
that you weren't actually with or i
think it was just more like i was more
grown and i just knew like
you know when you just feel like you
understand emotions a little bit more
and then that's just how it was and i
was like okay this is happening but i
was also like i was going to school in
boston
he was still in san francisco
and there was a lot of things like is
what and butts
and you know every time i came back like
we'd hang out all the time like
basically like every day when i was back
home
and then
when i was gone like it would just be
like
you know like every so often we'd
message each other but there was like
one time like oh
this is i wouldn't say this was cheating
because i can't say it was cheating
because we weren't together
it was like my second biggest heartbreak
because
it was like probably like winter and he
like told me he's like oh i'm with this
girl
but then in the summer
he was like oh i've been in a
relationship with this girl since the
summer
and i'm like okay
wait no sorry in the summer he told me
in the winter he said that that's when
it started i'm like okay
so
when we're here on spring break why
can't you tell me then yes because i
couldn't tell you because i didn't want
to and i'm like okay but why he goes
just cuz and i'm like
okay
and i literally that was oh that was on
the second time i went crazy again like
out of our drinking i was like throwing
punches i was screaming and crying like
in the alleyway
you were punching him thank you
you were punching him
not full-on i think i was just like is
that answer your crazy question yes
100
so one what i'm trying to say is
forever
but what i'm going to say most people
are imagine if a man came on a podcast
and said yeah i was punching this girl
and yeah i was going
yeah yeah yeah it's a double standard
it's
crazy yeah it's a double standard
oh my god i'll be cancelled tomorrow
i'll be cancelled
but
were you done with him after that
oh man it's not really oh dang i see
both loves kind of cheated on you then